I think it was very hard to learn
lessons from Rome learn direct lessons I
don't think that certainly there's much
where we can say oh look the Romans did
that and we should do it too they're all
I have to say quite a lot of things are
the Romans did things extremely badly I
I wouldn't a fancy being a woman in the
Roman Empire I certainly wouldn't a
fancy being a slave so we can see them
as as offering a rather angie model of
how you should treat women and the
conquered and I think that Rome makes us
think differently about some of the
problems that we have in which they face
- one of those most obviously and
particularly relevant you know at the
beginning of the 21st century his ideas
of migration and citizenship currently
refugees asylum seekers economic
migrants one of the biggest crises that
certainly the continent of Europe but
also the world more widely faces I think
for me very instructive to look back to
Rome and to see in worth to see in Rome
a world where there was no such thing as
an illegal migrant that would have been
absolutely incomprehensible to a Roman
whether was free movement of people
where people were granted citizenship by
the Romans very freely there was no such
thing as a citizenship test you didn't
have to salute the flag you didn't have
to sing the national anthem you didn't
have to pay a fee Rome was an
incorporating society and indeed when
Rome thought about its very origins who
founded Rome and they told elaborate
fantastic mythical stories like story of
Romulus and we
found in Rome after being being
discovered encircled by the wolf on the
banks of the Tiber or a different story
but equally popular how the Roman race
was founded by Aeneas who had been a
Trojan hero in the great war between the
Greeks and the Trojans at Troy and thus
had fled from Troy to find a new city in
Italy when his own had been defeated
look at those kind of stories you
discover the Romans are imagining their
origins in terms of being a home for
refugees like Aeneas and very
interestingly when Romulus actually
found the city that was on the site or
Rome itself and he looks around who
thinks help I haven't got any citizens
in poverty you know a couple of lads
nothing much more what does he do he
puts up a notice and sends messages
around saying Rome is a place of asylum
any runaway any criminal any asylum
seeker can come to Rome and be a Roman
citizen now it's extraordinary and
perhaps a rather more like some American
founding myths than some British
founding myths quite extraordinary to
see for me a a culture which traces its
origin back to migrants and refugees and
asylum seekers no I think it's very
important to say we can't just take that
as a model of what to do ourselves you
know it would be slightly crazy to say
oh because Rome was an open citizen city
and welcome to silence seekers it said
so should we you know we're living in a
different world but I think what's
important is simply the realization that
there is another culture back there that
had a very very different view from the
view that we now tend to hold and it
helps you put that view your own view in
perspective it helps you to see
that view from the outside Romans would
look at us and they look at what's
happening on the beaches of Europe and
the Mediterranean Sea you know their
world and they would be amazed and
horrified just as we are horrified but
some of the things that they did